time running short for westerners to
leave afghanistan the american embassy
is warning u.s citizens to stay away
from the country's main airport because
of the threat of violence yesterday the
secretary of state estimated about 1500
americans are still in afghanistan this
morning the u.s says more than 95
thousand people have been airlifted out
of the country in the past two weeks
some european countries are already
ending their evacuation efforts
denmark's defense minister says it is no
longer safe to fly in or out of kabul
charlie dagetta is in doha qatar where
many of those evacuees have arrived
good morning as if that desperate mass
evacuation couldn't get any more tense
there's now a specific threat that isis
in afghanistan could target the airport
and despite dire warnings thousands are
still gathering at the gates clinging to
any hope of getting out
that stark warning from the u.s state
department stay away and if you're
already there leave immediately a quote
very very credible intelligence report
that an isis attack is imminent has
forced america its allies even the
taliban to order people away from the
airport we believe that there is a very
imminent uh highly lethal attack
possible within kabul and as a
consequence we've had to change the
travel advice
that travel advice now head for the
borders to pakistan or tajikistan a
treacherous and unpredictable journey
isis k the afghan branch of isis is a
rival of the taliban and the two groups
have fought against each other in recent
years
they're responsible for some of the
worst atrocities the country has seen a
series of suicide car bombings killing
hundreds of civilians
that makes the airport an irresistible
target huge groups of people americans
among them the presence of u.s and
foreign forces and a chance to expose
the taliban's weakness but with only
five days left before u.s forces pull
out for good the despair of those two
terrified to stay is enough to take a
life and death risk to get away
the americans should shoot us or let us
through this woman says
those who did get through face an
uncertain future but one that provides
more safety and security than the world
they're leaving behind
and we're learning this morning that
these mass evacuations may be winding
down anyway the europeans will stop
their evacuations tomorrow while u.s
forces will begin to focus on
withdrawing remaining troops by august
31st
tony charlie dagger to force in doha
charlie thank you very much